darf ich den boden auf dem wir laufen
alles was ich aus gras befindet auf dem
boden bürger wie laufen aus schnee bauen
zu einem weitem mein quartier der
epischen legende und wir sind wieder
dabei
ich habe richtig viel electrics tab 7
nebeneinander oder gar keine
ich habe fünf nächte ein
bitte was krieg im gegenzug haben weiß
nicht was kann es mir dann geben
ich weiß es nicht
klingt gut was kann ich dir geben
es klingt gut annehmen dass er bestimmt
irgendwas du könnte mir ein camouflage
problemen aber diese heftig herzustellen
oder er gibt mir einfach zwei electric
stuff und gibt johanna das des tores
dorf getäuscht da wollte ich dir hier
camouflage blöcke ehrlich weil einmal
kräftig rezept durchziehen ist ja mal
krieg vier blöcke und ja okay ich weiß
nicht auf den fehler tausch ist aber ich
denke wir brauchen gehört beide beides
machen so ich gehe jetzt erstmal los und
zwar allem dachte ich mir kann man hier
so einen schönen eingang zaubern
wir sind gerade echt beide sozial wir
sind so weiter abbauen du sitzt für die
andere stadt ich zu viel für die
allgemeinheit weil wir denken uns auch
gar nichts böses bei das war aber auch
schon immer so wir sind die sozialen
wenn man den leuten das jetzt macht es
auf jeden fall so die menschen dass sie
da nicht raus können höhe
wir leben also und hier das passt denke
ich so über fehler
hier ist es natürlich um kurse
denn hier sollte das ganze so sein
kannst hier nicht mehr tropfen kann man
ja eigentlich covers machen
wika was also diese mini blöcke in mikro
blöcke es kann nicht was du meinst also
diese hand soll die man nämlich
megaprojekt ob die blöd auch gleich
glaube ja glaubst du weißt du ich glaube
wir haben sogar schon in der stadt wenn
du das meinst ja aber das ding ist kann
ich aus jedem block 1 kleineren block
ich hoffe die fans haben uns
eingeschrieben haben wir nicht leider
nein
vielleicht ist es dann irgendeine
spezial zeigt oder so aber wie wie hat
zombie das dann hier in seinem manifest
an ich weiß es wirklich nicht an der an
der wahlurne ist das wahlkabine so und
zwar wird das hier nicht noch nicht mal
liebe freude
das wird nicht nur eine bar passes witze
heißen nicht abgeguckt von home run ein
es wird ein stripclub das heißt das wird
aber ein bikini club und das bedeutet
harte drinks aber keine größte das heißt
immer im bikini aber dafür harte drinks
das wollen wale man wie baue ich denn
jetzt mein hohes haus hier ist endlich
gibt es für vips wie conny hinten eine
separate sektion wo man ein paar
dienstleistungen angebote ältere herren
auch gerne geschäft auf einem verrichten
weil das ein trend
kein problem
hotelier englisch gilt es raus ich packe
jetzt erst mal mein ganzes inventar rein
und dann werde ich jetzt sogar die
goldene feder jetzt welche anderen
kisten hierüber wollen heute werden die
edelsten und underground gamestar wir
hier als einziges die underground city
bauen
simon hat bisher nur ein kleines loch
gebuddelt und da gehört ihr die
handtasche zu ich bin jetzt schon mehr
underground wird wir beide sind schon
mehr underground als simon jemals war
wieso kann ich nicht so dass das lange
ich glaube ich wie kriegt man die kiste
hier kaputt wie ich doch welche kiste da
entscheide nicht ich brauche jetzt
einfach mal ab
diamond child also diese diamonds ist ja
erst mal meine fredericks dies in allem
besser ist natürlich die frage ist in
allem besser jaffray seit ex konzert
kostenlos verzaubern ich kann meiner
frisur tags heftiger euro funktioniert
heftiger dings abbauen heftiger steiner
abbauen als merke ich jetzt
nebeneinander jetzt kaputt gemacht glaub
ich so jetzt geht es endlich ab anja
freundl es wird später noch alles
sortiert heraus denn im tennis auf hallo
ich hatte gerade internet probleme
internet ich bin nicht weiter nächster
robot bleiben sie bei mir jetzt so alle
alle geht also ich höre ich zwar und
verstehe auch mit meinem hirn was du mir
sagen möchtest aber es ist wie als würde
c-3po mit mir reden ja das ist extra das
kann ich jetzt mit meiner stimme das
habe ich gelernt dass sondereffekt
pascal
sag mal fischers frisch du was ich meine
aber er ist elektro fische fischers
fritz frische fische zu müssen so
eigentlich ganz geil ich muss mir
angewöhnt mit links dazu bauen mit wie
heißt das teil mit kleinster und weil
dadurch dass ich auf einer spitzhacke
habe habe ich einfach immer nur
queenston in der hand und niemals mehr
kabel stone verrückt habe ich meiner jan
hammer nicht dabei bin ich bescheuert
noch ein idiot das los für die spirale
folgen lang las sie die kröten richtig
hängen
oh ja ich hab ein hammer der repariert
sich selbst der baut neuen blöcke
gleichzeitig ab alter scheiß auf dem big
eight ihren zahlen stecken und dann
nehme ich sie nicht mit und lass dir
einfach in die kiste ja auch gut bis auf
jeden fall eine ganz gute entscheidung
kanada vermacht jetzt habe ich sie dabei
jetzt heißt es
marburg meldet sich zum dienst support
in diesem komischen ständig up motto des
puffs ich doch schon ganz anders aus
also ich setze meine idee hier in frage
wollen wir vielleicht anstatt in unserer
stadt anstatt gras was einfach einfach
was anderes nehmen
das war eine menge arbeit das die wärme
hier ist es ja nix hier ist natürlich
überall gras in der stadt also 38 statt
gras untergrund wie wär's mit schnitten
schnees zu weisen obwohl schnee kommt
mal machen ja was steht dass wer weiß
mit marmor und schmilzt schnee mich ist
das mit schnee schmilzt keine undercover
testkäufer mal zum testen ganze paar
materialien die in folge fällt schnee
richtig geil schnee würdigt feiern und
ich vielleicht ich kann das einfach
aufnehmen
ich kann das gleich einfach mal neben
links setzen da probiere einfach mal aus
das könnte glaube ich gut kommen könnte
ich mir vorstellen
nicht schlecht herr specht da bin ich ab
da bin ich stolz auf dich ja ich hole
meine sachen hier irgendwie wieder die
ich gerade gar nicht wieder phänomene
dauer teil anders halten und ich weiß
jetzt wie mein bordell heißt zum ewigen
ständer ein schöner muss wird eine
kirche mit strip club alter der namen
finde ich schön krass wird epic
ich weiß die phobie club und schnittiger
schneller weniger ständer fackeln
kohleblöcke machen
ein also ich mich auch ehrlich gesagt
gerne ich glaube ich mache ich eine
portal tür zum ewigen ständer aber das
darfst du niemandem verraten
ich muss die fusion club und weißt du
was ich mache meine portal tür zum
untergrund jetzt ihr damit ich direkt in
den ewigen standard pocket der menschen
das darfst du nicht erzählen okay was
soll ich niemandem erzählen haben wir
vergessen also noch habe ich da nichts
gebaut
war ich bin so dumm ich habe gar keine
fackeln irgendwie muss ja in städten
setzen
er kann gerne fackeln ab habe ich kohle
ich habe das nie abgebracht hier steht
die bar plus
foto ari hier entsteht der strip club
der strip club zum wiegen ständer
darunter kommt ein schild hin
hofmann doppelpunkt kev durch den schnee
blogger abbauen halter schnee bio also
nicht schnee einfach da drauf legen sie
dann einfach so eisblöcke abbauen quasi
so als schnee blöcke quasi na also
du musst ja schnee kräften mit dem
vingster weiß noch nie also kann
plötzlich aus dem steht wie hunger du
kannst ja auch ganz normalen schnee den
oberflächlichen abbauen
der kriegt ja vier schneebälle nee ich
meine jetzt diese richtigen schnee
blöcke hier die kann ich auch einfach ab
und an noch dürfen geht dann ist ja okay
gut so dass auch hier entscheidend zum
ewigen ständer puffmutter und besitzer
kfh alter wie schnell das geht schnell
abzubauen
ich persönlich ja ich finde das immer
doof wenn man produktiv ist und so viel
machen will und an der nächsten folge
der ich mir dann wieder summen okay was
man jetzt nicht aber ich baue meine
ganzen schnee ab und wird das jetzt mal
neben die sting setzen
neben diesen
babbel was wir da haben ob das denn gut
aussieht so ich muss jetzt natürlich den
puff auch so bauen dass wir diverse
separees zur verfügung haben
allerdings sollten wir auch mal geht es
um die fragen oder was sie davon halten
von was von john ja aber wir können
einfach kündigen chocobo fragen und
fahrig die magische miesmuschel genau
was wir machen jetzt stimmt wir wollen
das ja ein filmstar bin
unsere königin gefragt wird dann muss
man mit der magischen social app einmal
nachfragen da wir jetzt gar nicht mehr
abbauen und fragen jetzt dass man die
königin ja genau so spielt mal wieder
zurück bin schockiert ist natürlich
selbstverständlich fährt sehr schnell so
ok habe ich einen kleinen fehler gemacht
wie ich gerade so schoko tobago die
erste nix ich habe eine frage an dich
meine selbst dame
ich habe eine frage nicht probeabo
jetzt ist nur das intro dafür darf ich
in unserer stadt habe ich überhaupt die
richtigen einstellungen ja habe ich darf
ich in dürftet ihr könnt sogar sehen war
die musik bei mir aus dem alles
relativiert negativ neutral und positiv
alles aktiviert so darf ich in unserer
stadt so wenn ich hier drin
darf ich in unserer stadt alles aus
schnee und die magische miesmuschel sie
wird entscheiden
denkt nicht lange darüber nach einfach
noch nein du hast die frage falsch
gestellt du hast gesagt darfst du alles
auszubauen
das heißt soll es die frage präzisieren
darfst du den fußboden aus schnee bauen
darf ich den boden auf dem wir laufen
alles was ich aus gras befindet auf dem
boden wieder gelaufen aus schnee bauen
wo hast du dich erwarten jetzt eine
frage ja ok wat ich muss wieder zu ihr
hin
frage muss ich von crafter die die vier
magischen blöcke geben im gegensatz zu
diesen zwei electric ist eine blöde
frage mit ja aber du gibst du mir so
oder so nur gucken was er sagen würde
was ich sagen würde weil das ist ein
tausch und uns nicht von der königin zu
tun
du gibst du mir sonst kriegst du nicht
die elektrik stars ich ziehe mich an der
schnur eine frage also musst du musst
nichts von crafter items geben wenn ich
mit ihm tauschen
oktober wo die erste war es richtig dass
wir ins haus abgerissen haben
es war möglich wir haben gemacht so war
es denn richtig haben wir denn richtig
gehandelt was für willst du ärger ja
genau das hat auch ärger wichtig ist hat
auch ärger erfolgen natürlich war es
denn die richtige entscheidung was sagst
du so ganz aus dem inneren chocobo die
erst war es die richtige entscheidung
gemacht
ok zweite frage was immer welche frage
heilige chocobo leben wir in der matrix
das wort geplante cobo denkst du
könntest mehr als eine amtszeit unsere
königin sein eventuell irgendwann wieder
gewählt werden ich muss erst mal ganz
schnell wieder weg jetzt einfach die
blöcke mache ich bei meinem grundstück
nur das ist bescheuert
ich finde das richtig richtig geil dass
wir die magische miesmuschel als können
knabenchor sie also zu kuba die erstes
natürlich selbst wahrscheinlich die
königin entscheidet also ich find's cool
den rest kennt nicht schmeckt einfach
raus so der strip club muss natürlich
auch von unten und oben glänzen was
eigentlich kkw nicht das zu bauen obwohl
doch da noch was von denen ich begrüße
man die ganzen intentionen so wie ich
das jetzt so während es bei uns ich weiß
wie es bei dir ist ich mache mir da voll
gar nicht viel gedanken also ich hab mir
jetzt echt sagt gar keine gedanken macht
wie zum beispiel ein stripclub aufbau
und zwischendurch fällt mir immer auf
sagt guck mal die decke da müsste doch
noch das hin
dann müssen auch noch dies sind oder die
ist das glaube ich genauso ja genau ich
geh einfach hierhin und ich weiß so
circa so wie groß das werden sollen und
was alles aber wo genau irgendwas ist
weiß nicht keine ahnung digitalen einmal
luft und das halte ich einfach nur
inspiriert ich lasse sie gar nicht
außerdem sorry jetzt zum beispiel ich
mir zb gedacht wäre okay ich wusste ja
zum beispiel gerade nicht wo kommt ein
schoko bestellen
aber jetzt habe ich das hier sieht da
packe ich mir doch lieber hier sodann
einen kleinen stall dann einfach also
ich werde definitiv noch mal bei mir auf
räume müssen weil wenn ich hier hat
einer decke baue ich sie jetzt bloß
selbstgespräche so die scale rüstung ist
zum bauen echt entspannt habe tief
rüstung müssen immer direkt am anderen
ende des grundstücks genau hier muss es
nämlich auch so tief sein außer dem
grund weil wir sehen hier scheint der
wasserspiegel ein bisschen tiefer zu
sein
das heißt aber herunter gehen dann ist
das so schon korrekt richtig choral so
hier kommen entstanden ist dieses corp
da sind die 5 ich nehme so ein paar
blöcke eindrücklich choral 81 koralle
von nicole von spongebob
doch damit nicht genug corax weißer
dekoration ist oder kontaktlisten
bockmann corax so ist der von wiesdorf
von the next uri geller damals
balasko so sagt mir wie es in der
anderswelt so ist ich weiß nur dass uri
geller damals tante fast ertrunken wäre
sondern eine komische frau da und was
bringt lumberjacks gar nichts nix aber
nachgefragt und mir wurde tatsächlich
gesagt kannst wegwerfen das bringt so
erstmal nichts dann schmeiß weg ich
dachte das ist wertvoll oder so leuchtet
da so komisch rum leuchtet da so komisch
rumpel hinten nix hier baue ich mir eine
kleine tür rein wenn es erstmal einen
komischen abschluss hier machen
ich finde wir sind richtig geil wir wir
bauen hier wichtig gut und es läuft
eigentlich griffbrett kann ich ja direkt
wegschmeißen man ist ja eben mehr oder
weniger verboten
ja genau das riff armee wird behalten
weiß aber mal okay das ist dass sie
wirklich sogar dass du so eine
absperrung hier entsteht der skript luft
zum ewigen ständer ich vorher das
einfach nur lüge ständer ist nicht mehr
fern
die suche ist beendet brüder und
schwestern kaum mit ihr diesen klub und
lasst euch einen örtlichen ständer mache
muss ich alleine kämpfen fragen die sich
nie warum brüdern und ich kann machen
was ich will also selbst wenn ich jetzt
auch zu hause so irgendwas gesagt das
bin halt ich glaube mein ganzes leben
als und so eine scheiße und deswegen
mich der geborene lutz player
ich bin noch ein bisschen ein amokfahrer
wir haben noch
zwei minuten sehe ich gerade oder
anderthalb ja da wäre ich jetzt einfach
noch ein bisschen xp vom sammeln gehen
um das ganze dann schmerzte packen
ich will ich glaub ich glaube ich dem
notebook einfach runter von meinem
schwert das ego kacke ja noch mal habe
ich auch gar nicht drauf habe ich das
auto auch drauf ja ich habe noch beck
eins drauf aber das bringt nichts aber
der strip club da muss ja nicht wichtig
was hermachen
ja ich hab das ja noch nicht gesehen
jeder kommt mal kurz her das kannst du
doch kurz mal einziehen denke ich bin
der bock hast ja was ich schaffe ich das
jetzt noch klarer aussage ich habe das
nur dummerweise ein zu hoch gebaut und
ich werde dann im livestream hier
weiterbauen wenn ich freu mich wie
gesagt wir ich bin jetzt nicht anti
untergrund aber ich bin jetzt auch nicht
untergrund pro ich bin halt ein
korrupter nachtclub-besitzer sowie das
halt ist und deswegen ich bin auf weg zu
dir ja wo ich warte auf dich so jetzt
bin ich in einer dimension
statt rot zack zack das hier wird die
bar aber billig in stadtroda aber wie
komme ich raus muss hier raus heraus ich
habe da noch diesen unsichtbarkeit blog
so aber sogar auslaufen müssten raus wer
crazy ich komme gar zum untergrund
richtig falls es schon richtig fein war
das ist echt schön hier entsteht der
strip druck zum ewigen ständer
puffmutter besitzer kirche sind ja das
ist ein super g
ja wie gesagt hier werden separees sein
das heißt die kopten tisch im hegau
eigene couch in gewartet wie ein
billardtisch und einen pool er ist ein
stripclub ihr da gibt's keine politische
hacker ist fasten stripclub nein
billard tischkicker als priester machen
oder ja eigentlich schon kommt drauf an
wie viel besuchter immer so drin sein
wird ich bin jetzt größer habe ich sie
dass wir sozusagen die männer das
ist echt ein bisschen komisch aber fällt
das auf nein wenn man sich weiß nicht
schreibt es nicht weiter
das darfst du nicht sagen da ist es
schon woanders statt blau und freunde
tatsächlich gefallen hat dann lassen die
wert oder wenn ihr euch freut dass wir
so produktiv sind ich habe in diesen in
dieser aufnahme ist zwischen diesen drei
folgen jetzt geschafft dass mein haus
komplett weg ist und hier an dieser
stelle entsteht nun ein neues haus der
jobo steinhaus ich das connector jetzt
um den rest der verein schreibt mir die
kommentare wir den ewigen ständer findet
was habt ihr für ideen was für locations
soll ich da die bauern sollten haus
bereich geben wie bereich wo sollen dann
doch mal zu sehen sein trotz des bikini
klubs nicht vergessen popow die
eisenbahn und dann bleibt kein voll
gemacht